اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير متابعينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها هذا
المساء
بين سوريا وتركيا خارطه طريق روسيه هل
تنجح في تقريب مسار التطبيع بين البلدين
ام ان الخلافات ستصعب طريقها
[موسيقى]
الثاني ترامب يدفع ببراءته في قضيه
الوثائق السريه ويصر على الترشح كيف ستؤثر
معركته القانونيه على سباق الرئاسي
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى تفاصيل الملف الاول بين سوريا
وتركيا خريطه طريق روسيا قد تنجح في اعاده
قطيعه سنوات طويله وفي حل خلافات جذريه
كبيره نبا عوده العلاقات بين دمشق وانقره
اتى من موسكو الوسيط الذي يسعى من مده الى
تقريب المسافه وان بدت بعيده بشهاده موسكو
نفسها ايضا نائب وزير الخارجيه ميخائيل
بوغدانوف صرح بان مسوده خريطه الطريق
للتطبيع بين سوريا وتركيا التي وضعتها
بلاده باتت جاهزه وان المهام الان تكمن في
مناقشه مسوده والمضي قدما فيها كما قال
خاصه خلال اجتماعين وبوزراء خارجيه روسيا
وسوريا وتركيا وايران والذي سيعقد بعد
اسبوع في استانا في المقابل وفي تصريحات
اعلاميه كشفنا بعثوا الرئيس الروسي الخاص
الى سوريا الكسندرة ان مواقف البلدين
بعيده عن بعضها البعض لا الى صعوبه
استعاده ما دمر على مدار 12 عاما خلال
اسابيع او خلال اشهر ووفق حديث السفير
الروسي فالامور ليست سيئه بمجملها على
اعتبار ما تحقق على مسار تطبيع العلاقات
السوريه العربيه كذلك في موضوعنا اخر كان
عبر المبعوث الاممي او المبعوثه الروسي عن
اعتقاده بان تكون اعاده العلاقات وانتخاب
اردوغان لفتره رئاسيه جديده عاملا ايجابيا
في هذا السياق
مسوده خارطه الطريق بين سوريا وتركيا في
موسكو اجتمع وزيره خارجيه تركيا وسوريا في
الشهر الماضي بمشاركه وزيري خارجيه ايران
وروسيا كان الاجتماع الاول منذ عام 2011
تمحور حول وضع خارطه طريق تهدف الى تطبيع
العلاقات بين دمشق وانقره اتفق خلاله
وزراء الدول الاربع بتكليف نوابهم باعداد
خارطه طريق لتطوير العلاقات بين دمشق
وانقره وزير الخارجيه الروسي قال حينها ان
هذه الخارطه ستسمح لدمشق وانقر بتحديد
موقفيهما بوضوح بشان القضايا ذات الاولويه
بالنسبه اليهما بهدف استعاده الحكومه
السوريه السيطره على كامل اراضي البلاد
ولتضمن بقوه امن الحدود مع تركيا التي
يبلغ طولها 900 كيلومتر ووفق لافروف تتضمن
خارطه الطريق مبادئ اعد اهمها احترام
سياده سوريا ووحده وسلامه اراضيها واحترام
جميع المشاركين بالميثاق الامم المتحده
وكذلك الحفاظ على علاقات الجوار الوديه
معولا على التعاون الوثيقي لمكافحه
الارهاب بجميع اشكاله اضافه الى استعاده
الروابط اللوجسيه التي قطعت بين البلدين
واستئناف التعاون الاقتصادي دون اي عوائق
القضايا الخلافيه بين تركيا وسوريا
سوريا تصف تركيا بالمحتله لاراضيها فيما
تقول تركيا انها تحاول رسم حزام امني
يقيها مما تصفها بمخاطر ارهاب الاكراد
تركيا مهتمه بمنطقه خفض التصعيد في ادلب
وتصر على اقامه منطقه عازله بعمق 30
كيلومترا شمالي سوريا الجيش التركي موجود
في سوريا بموجب اتفاقيه اضنه اتفاقيه اضنه
وقعت جانبان عام
1998 تلزم الجانبين بمنع الجماعات
الارهابيه من الدخول الى اراضي البلدين
فيما يسمح للجيش التركي الدخول حتى عمق
خمسه كيلو مترات لملاحقه الجماعات
الارهابيه واتخاذ التدابير الامنيه
اللازمه اذا تعرض امنه تركيا القومي للخطر
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من دمشق يوسف
الكاتب الصحفي والمفروض انه بعد قليل كذلك
سينضم لنا زاهد رئيس تحرير انزيم تركي
ولكن سابدا معك من دمشق استاذ غسان استاذ
غسان هذه المرحله في الواقع حضرتك تعلم
بانه منذ فتره والجهود
تتطور شيء باتجاه امكانيه ايجاد حلول
حقيقيه لتطبيع العلاقات السوريه التركيه
ولكن هذه المره التصريحات الروسيه لفتت
الجدل وقيل بانه هذه التصريحات لا تبدو
تصريحات تدعو للتفاؤل حضرتك كيف تقرا اولا
هذه التصريحات وهذه المرحله من المساعي
لتقريب وجهه النظاره الثنائيه
تحياتي لك
هذه هي المره الوحيده التي تصريحات
الروسيه صريحه وواضحه وواقعيه باعتبار
يعني لاحظي مثلا انك كثير الروسي في دمشق
وهو ممثل الرئيس
كيف قال اما يعني هناك 12 سنه هناك 12 سنه
من القطيعه بين البلدين وتحتاج الى العمل
الكثير للوصول الى تفاهمات ايضا يعني
لاحظنا بانو قال يعني بعد
بان الوثيقه اصبحت جاهزه وانها ستعرض على
مجموعه التيتانا في الحادي والعشرين من
الشهر الحالي اذا نحن اليوم امام اصبحنا
امام ورق يعني امام بنون متفق عليها في
نتودى وهذه البنود اذا لاحظتي اكدت على
وحده الاراضي السوريه وايضا على سيطره
سوريا على كافه اراضيها وعلى يعني محاربه
الارهاب
المسار الاقتصادي وعوده اللاجئين وغير ذلك
ولذلك اعتقد باننا اليوم دخلنا الى
المرحله الجلديه مرحله التفاوض الحقيقي
بين البلدين برعايه روسيه وحضور ايراني
ولذلك انا انا اقول لك يعني هناك تفاؤل
ولكن هذا التفاؤل هذه لماذا لانه يعود الى
النوايا التركيه
ولكن في المقابل تركيا تقول انوايا
السوريه واسمح لي بما ان ضيفنا غير حاضر
معنا ان اكون في نقل لوجهه النظر المقابله
تسمح لي بذلك استاذ غسان يعني انقل لك
نحاول ان نتجادل بخصوص هذا الموضوع طيب
سوريا لديها فرصه كان هناك خطوه اولى وهو
عودتها الى جامعه الدول العربيه والان
هناك محاوله ثانيه من تركيا من تركيا
تتحدث عن تصفير المشاكل وماده يدها الى
سوريا لمحاوله تذليل العقبات على الاقل
ولكن سوريا تتعنت تتعنت لماذا لماذا تصعب
المهمه على تركيا
السؤال لي ام
انك انت ضيف الوحيد في هذه المرحله وانا
وانا اعتبرني الضيف المقابل يعني ههه
تفضل تفضل ولا يهمك نحن نتناقش
بواقعيه انا اقول لك كوريا لا تتعنت ولكن
سوريا لديها ارض محتله لديها مجموعات
ارهابيه موجوده ومصنفه على قوائم الارهاب
الدولي لديها مقاتلين اجانب دخلوا من
تركيا وهم موجودون في الاراضي السوريه
ايضا لديها مجموعات رادكاليه كانت في داعش
ويعني اصبحت اليوم فيما يسمى الجيش الوطني
وايضا هناك عمليات تغيير ديموغرافي تجري
على الارض السوريه وايضا عمليات
الدوله
تغيير ديموغرافي تركيا تسميه محاوله الحفظ
على الامن القومي تركي كذلك من مصلحتها ان
تحافظ على امنها كما تقول تصريحات تركيا
الرسميه بان تدافع على حدودها وهي تقول
بانه هذه المنطقه هي منطقه انا اؤمنها
واحاول ان على الاقل احافظ على سلامه
المواطنين من الجهه التركيه الى حين وجود
حلول جذريه
لنتناقض كما
اولا يعني من تقوم تركيا بامكانهم في تلك
المناطق هي مناطق فجر اهلها يعني مثلا
عفرين اعزاز الراعي غير ذلك الباب
وتم اسكان يعني من حصلوا على الجنسيه
التركيه وتمت اعادتهم وليس عودتهم اعادتهم
الى هذه المناظر
وتين في هذه المناطق على الرغم يعني من ان
قوانين الامم المتحده وقوانين عوده
اللاجئين تقول بعوده اللاجئ الى حيه الى
بيته الى المكان الذي كان يسكن فيه وهذا
ما هو متفق عليه دوليا وهذا ما تسعى اليه
سوريا بان يعود اللاجئون ضوئيا الى مكان
سكناهم وهذا خلاف كبير بين سوريا
وروسيا من جهه مع تركيا من جهه اخرى هذا
من جهه من جهه اخرى اذا كانت تركيا تريد
ان تحمي انها القومي فانا اقول لك عليها
اولا ان تعود الى اتفاقيه اضن ان تعد
بالاتفاق مع الجانب السوري وبرعايه طبيه
او ان يكون هناك اتفاق جديد بين البلدين
يضمن الامن القومي للبلدين باعتبار يعني
كما ان لتركيا امن قومي لسوريا ايضا امن
قومي هذا فيما يخص اتفاقيه ثم يخص ما
اسميته بمحاوله تغيير الديموغرافي لكن
ماذا عن القوات الاجنبيه لما تتكلم حضرتك
عن قوات اجنبيه سيقول لك كذلك الجانب
التركي بان هناك قوات اجنبيه اخرى هناك
قوات ايرانيه هناك قوات روسيه ولا زالت
هناك قوات امريكيه ومع كل هذا علاقات
سوريا ممتازه معهم لماذا تقف على القوات
الاجنبيه التركيه فقط
تماما جيد جدا لتعرفين بان كل دوله لديها
علاقات مع دوله اخرى مثلا تركيا لديها
علاقات مع الولايات المتحده وهناك قواعد
امريكيه موجوده في تركيا هل تتدخل كوريا
في هذا الموضوع اعتقد انها بالنسبه
لعلاقتنا مع روسيا هي علاقه دوله لدوله
وهناك وايضا ايران ولكن بالنسبه لتركيا
تركيا دخلت من دون اتفاق ابدا مع الدوله
السوريه كما الولايات المتحده ولذلك لا
تجوز المقارنه البعض يقول لك ليخرج
الايرانيون والروس وثم ليخرج الاتراك
والامريكان هذا غير صحيح لان يعني بشرعه
الامم المتحده الامم المتحده يحق لاي دوله
ان تتفق مع اي دوله اخرى وحتى اقامه قواعد
عسكريه وحتى
غسان لم افهم لماذا تعامل سوريا
وكانه هناك كيل بمكيالين بين القوات
الاجنبيه التركيه والقوات الاجنبيه
الايرانيه الروسيه الى اخره باختصار شديد
لانه ضيف نصار جاهز معنا التحق بنا هنا في
الاستوديو زاهد رئيس تحرير اتفضل اكمل
الفكره وصلت غسان تحياتي للاستاذ محمد
طبعا
ولكن انا اقول لك يعني انا قلت لك لا لا
توجد
ولكن اقول لك سوريا تعاملت مع روسيا
الاتحاقيات الدوله لدوله ومع ايران دوله
اما دخول تركيا فكان بدون اتفاق مع الدوله
السوريه وايضا دخول الولايات المتحده ايضا
كان بدون اتفاق مع الدوله السوريه
استاذ زاهد حاولت ان ادافع عن وجهه النظر
التركيه بما انه حضرتك تاخرت علينا قليل
اذا تاخرت
حضرتك
كان يتحدى ضيفي ويقول بانه
المخطئ او على الاقل من لا يدفع في مسار
تقارب حقيقي سوري تركي هو الجانب التركي
لانه محتل اولا الاراضي السوريه وهذا فعل
قائم واقع ولان كذلك هناك قوه اجنبيه على
داخل او في داخل السوري كيف يمكن ان ترد
على مثل هكذا تصريحات
بدايه ان التحيه الطيبه لك ولضيفك الكريم
والجميع مشاهدي قناه يعني اعتقد
ان المشهد ابتداء ليس تركي فقط السوري
بالمشهد الاقليمي ايضا اصبح في اختلافات
جذريه وجوهريه في اطار النظر للمساله
السوريه اولا وللمسائل الاخرى المتعلقه
بالمساله السوريه او بالمسائل المنطقه
الثانيه وبالتالي اعتقد ان المقاربات
التركيه وغير التركيه حقيقه تجاه المساله
السوريه اعتقد انها اصبحت مقاربات مختلفه
عن سابقي عهديها بمعنى اننا في الوقت
الراعي لا يمكننا فقط الحديث عن وجود قوات
اجنبيه لا يمكننا الحديث فقط عن بعض
المشكلات هنا وهناك المقاربه اعتقد ان
التركيه ابتداء وانتهاء تركيا اذا كانت
موجوده بعد ايام مع وزراء الخارجيه
الاربعه في الاسيتانه في 21 من الشهر
الحالي
فالمقاربه التركيه ستكون من اجل ايجاد
الحل ابتداء وانتهاء وبالتالي التي تقدمها
تتحدث عن مجموعه النقاط ولكن تقول بان
هناك مقاربه تركيه وكانك في طرح حل شامل
وليس في تحليل كل هذه النقاط واخذ كل نقطه
او كل خلاف موضع طرح على طويله النقاش
مؤكد ان الشيطان يكمن في التفاصيل ومن
المؤكد ان هناك وجهات نظر متباينه ومختلفه
عن فيما بين الاطراف فيما يتعلق بكل قضيه
على حده لكن انا اعتقد ان اراده الحل اذا
كانت موجوده على الطاوله من الاطراف
المعنيين ابتداء وانتهاء من المؤكد انهم
سيتوصلون الى حلول مرضيه لكل الاطراف هذه
يعني كمبدا اساسي ابتداء في المقاربه
بمعنى يقول بانه ليست هناك اراده تركيه
حقيقيه انا اعتقد ابتداء وانتهاء اذا كنا
نتحدث عن علاقه تركيه مع نظام دمشق خلال
السنوات الماضيه فكان مهندس هذه العلاقه
او صاحب هذه العلاقه الوحيده ربما كان
رئيس الجهاز والامن الذي تراس حقيبه
الخارجيه الان فهو اكثر انسان في تركيا
مطلع على تفاصيل العلاقه مع نظام دمشق
بالجهه وعلاقاته المباشره خلال السنوات
القليله الماضيه مع الفاعلين السياسيين في
دمشق وبالتالي اعتقد انه سيقدم مقاربه الى
حد كبير مختلفه عن سابقه وسلفه وبالتالي
اعتقد انه يمكن التوصول الى تفاهمات اسرع
واعمق مما كان عليه في السابق السابق كنا
نتحدث ربما عن تفاهمات في قضايا امنيه
بسيطه الان نتحدث ربما عن رؤيه شامله اكثر
للكثير من القضايا الملحه بين الطرفين
ولكن لم نتحدث ما تتحدث حضرتك عن راس
الاستخبارات الذي صار يراس وزاره الخارجيه
وتتحدث عن رؤيه تركيه جديده وكانك تقر
بانه في السابق لم تكن هناك اراده حقيقيه
او اليه حقيقيه والان تغير كل شيء باختصار
حتى انقل هذه النقطه لضع اعتقد نسبيا صحيح
يعني كنا نتحدث قبل اشهر ان العلاقه
التركيه السوريه او حتى رغبه الرئيس
اردوغان بلقاء بشار الاسد له علاقه بموضوع
الترحيل اللاجئين له علاقه بموضوع السوري
فيما يتعلق بالانتخابات التركيه وعدم ايضا
قبول دمشق بهذه المطالب ابتداء وانتهاء ان
لا تريد ان تقدم ورقه للسيد اردوغان في
اطار حملته الانتخابيه وما الى ذلك هكذا
كنا نتحدث او هكذا كنا نقول وهكذا كان
يقول الامريكيون ايضا يعني
[موسيقى]
السفير الامريكي
السابق في دمشق تحدث في مقالي له في جريده
الشرق الاوسط ان هذا شهر عسل مؤقت ستنتهي
مع نهايه الانتخابات اليوم حقيقه نحن
نتحدث عن مسار لا اعتقد انه جديد ابتداء
لكنه مسار اعتقد انه سيكون مختلفا عن
المسار الذي كنا نتحدث عنه قبل الانتخابات
بشكل مؤكد طيب خلينا ندخل شويه في تفاصيل
معك يا استاذه غسان كنا نتحدث سنعود
للحديث عن شمال سوريا ولكن ماذا عن عوده
اللاجئين ملف شديد الحساسيه
وهناك خلافات عميقه بين الجانبين فيما يخص
عوده اللاجئين تركيا تقول بانه اللاجئون
السوريون او ان اللاجئين السوريين اثقلوا
اقتصادنا نحن نتحدث عن ما يقارب الاربعه
ملايين اعداد رسميه ولكن قد تكون الاعداد
اكبر فيما منتقد
الجانب السوري يقولون بان سوريا تستعمل
هذا الملف للضغط على ملفات اخرى هل هناك
اراده ورغبه حقيقيه سوريه في فتح هذا
الملف وفي ايجاد حلول له
يعني بدايه انا ساذكر كريم بما قاله
الرئيس التركي اردوغان يعني في حمله
الانتخابيه او بعد الحمله الانتخابيه
مباشره الى قناه بي ان ان الامريكيه عندما
قال نحن نريد عوده طوعيه للاجئين ولكن
هناك بعض اللاجئين الذين نحتاجهم في
الاعمال وفي
الزراعه والصناعه وغير ذلك ولذلك يعني
تركيا ليست مستعجله لعوده اللاجئين هي
تقول بانها تستفيد منهم منهم على لسان
الرئيس التركي من جهه اخرى كما قلت لك
يعني هي تعيدهم بالطريقه التي هي تريدها
زاهد استاذ زاهد تحتاجون الى 4 مليون سوري
كي يد عامله
لا لا هو لم يقل اربعه مليون قال نحتاجه
بعضهم بعضهم مش اربعه مليون استاذ غسان
نحن نتحدث عن ملايين هو لما يقول بانه
نحتاج الى بعضهم ربما سيحتاج الى الالاف
او عشرات الالاف على اقصى تقدير لما يتحدث
عن انه سيمكنني من العوده ولكن استاذ غسان
لما يقول بانه سنمكنهم من العوده بطريقه
اختياريه يعني لن نطردهم لن نقوم بطردهم
ولكن الموضوع يثقل اقتصاد تركيا يعني من
المؤكد ان هناك مقاربه ايضا جديده في هذا
الموضوع يعني لاول مره موضوع عوده
اللاجئين وموضوع اللاجئين السوريين لاول
مره كان في الاجتماع الاول لمجلس الامن
القومي التركي وفي بياناه الاول في قبل
اسبوع تم الحديث عن عوده او ضروره اعاده
اللاجئين عوده طوعيه خلال الفتره القادمه
وبالتالي هناك ايضا مقاربه سياسيه وامنيه
دعني اقول جديده في حكومه السيد اردوغان
الجديده تتحدث بشكل واضح وصريح لاول مره
وتم طرح هذا الموضوع في مجلس الامن القومي
التركي الذي هو يعتبر اهم مجلس لاتخاذ
القرارات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه بمعنى ان
الكثير من القوانين والكثير من التوصيات
الامنيه والاداريه ستاتي بناء على هذا
القرار الذي تم اتخاذه وبالتالي من المؤكد
ان هناك سيكون تسارع حقيقه في اطار مقاربه
عوده اللاجئين السوريين الى المواطن
نعم ولكن هل تركيا او في تركيا هناك احساس
بان سوريا تعول على هذا الملف بان سوريا
ترغب فعليا في عوده اللاجئين
شخصيا انا لا اعتقد ان هناك رغبه سوريه
ابتداء دعنا نقول هذا الكلام بوضوح لكن
تركيا حقيقه من خلال شركائها الدوليين
والاقليميين لا شك انها ستسعى الى ايجاد
الوسائل والسبل التي تضمن عوده اللاجئين
الى داخل الاراضي السوريه بمعنى انها
ستؤمن لهم يعني كما يقول دمشق الامور لما
تقول لانه لا اشعر بان هناك رغبه سوريه
وفيما بعد تتحدث عن انه يمكن ايجاد ضمانات
وكانك تقول يمكن ايجاد ملفات للضغط على
دمشق لمحاوله طرح حلول لعوده اللاجئين
المساله لا تتعلق بضغط على دمشق بقدر ما
يتعلق ايضا ان اللاجئ السوري يعني دعنا
نتحدث بواقعيه غالبيه اللاجئين ليسوا
معارضه سياسيه بالمفهوم التقليدي وليسوا
معارضين سياسيين ولانه او لم يخرجوا
بالضروره لانهم معارضين سياسيين هم خرجوا
غالبيتهم العظمى لانهم لم يجدوا الامان
الكافي ولم يجدوا ايضا وسائل الاعاشه
الكافيه في هذه المنطقه في ظروف اقتصاديه
ظروف الحرب وبالتالي اذا تاملت بعض هذه
الظروف في المناطق السوريه المتعدده
المختلفه من المؤكد انهم سيعودون الى
بلادهم في اطار
عوده طبيعيه في سياق طبيعي للغايه
وبالتالي اذا تامن السكن على الاقل واذا
تامل بعض سبل العمل المريح في المناطق
السوريه المختلفه عبر دعم دولي واقليمي
وبالتالي
سيسهل عوده الاف اللاجئين صحيح لانه ملف
حساس ان كان لك سيد غسان تعليق على مقاله
ضيفي بخصوص الرغبه السوريه هو يقول استشعر
بانه ليست هناك رغبه سوريه حقيقيه لعودتهم
بالنسبه للاستاذ محمد يعني
محمد جاهز
عقدت اكثر من مؤتمر لعوده اللازمه
السوريين هي يعني اصدرت الكثير من
المراثيم ومراثيم العفو يعني بما يخص
المتخلفين الخدمه العسكريه وهذا يسهل عوده
الشباب ودفع البدائل ايضا بالنسبه للذين
خرجوا يعني بسبب الوضع الامني وبسبب
الضائق الاقتصاديه وغير ذلك او التحق
باولادهم او غير ذلك فانا حبيت يعني انا
دوله سوريا وعلى لسان وزير الخارجيه
والمسؤولية وحتى تضمن عوده اللاجئين
السوريين
وترحب بعوده اللاجئين السوريين وهي على
اتصال مع الحكومه الاردنيه اللبنانيه ايضا
في المفاوضات التي ستجري في في ستكون على
اتصال مع الحكومه التركيه ولكن كما قلت لك
سوريا تريد ان يعود اللاجئ الى حيه الى
منزله الى المكان الذي كان به وليس هذا
عادي يعني صحيح
لانه لانه خرجوا
خرجوا لاسباب الحرب ولاسباب الظروف
الاقتصاديه وظروف المعيشيه الموقع
الاقتصادي واذا كان هناك يعني تفعيل
العلاقات العربيه مع سوريا ودعم اقتصادي
وعوده واعاده اعمار خصوصا يعني استمعنا
الكثير من الدول التي اتت اعدادها لاعاده
الاعمال السعوديه
روسيا ايران غير ذلك انا اعتقد بان هذا
الموضوع سيحل تدريجيا ولكن يعني تطوري انت
لديك حوالي خمسه او سته مليون لاجئ ستحل
مشكلتهم خلال يوم وليله انا لا اعتقد
يوم ليله ولكن على الاقل يعني البعض يريد
ان يبدا في متابعه شيء فعلي وليس حوارات
او لانه موضوع جدا حساس موضوع اللاجئين
استاذ غسان موضوع الاكراد كذلك تركيا
تطالب بموقف واضح صريح
وحاسم من الاكراد شمال سوريا ولكن تتهم
كذلك حكومه دمشق بالصمت ما المنتظر من
حكومه دمشق فيما يخص هذا الموضوع
انا يعني هناك دائما اتكلم عن الخلاف سوري
تركي بشان موضوع الاكراد في شمال سوريا
تركيا تعتبر حزب العمال البرد الثاني حزما
ارهابيا وان حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي الذي
انشا قتل وهو يسيطر يعني بشكل عام على
المنطقه هو امتداد لحزب العمال الكردستاني
وهذا صحيح يعني لماذا لان يعني مثلا هذه
الاتحاد الديمقراطي هو يتبع نصف حقيده عز
العمال البرج الثاني يرفع صور اوجلان يعني
عندما قاموا بتحرير مناطق سوريا لم يرفعوا
مثلا
لضيق الوقت
لنذهب الى تفضل تفضل ثواني بس ريم يكون
الامر واضح لكن سوريا تعتبر هذه المجموعات
انفصاليه ويجب حل الموضوع داخليا بين
الدوله السوريه وهذه المجموعات الانفصاليه
يعني بالوصول الى
تصور ذاتي واتفاق معين بين الدوله وبين
هذه المكونات دون اتهامها بالارهاب
ومحاربتها واشعال حرب اهليه هل يمكن ان
يرضي هذا الطرح الجانب التركي بان تكون
هناك تسويه
داخليه سوريه سوريه
هذا ربما احد اوجه الخلاف بين الطرف
التركي والسوري تركيا كما قال ضيفك تعتبر
هذه الجماعات على انها جماعات ارهابيه
وتريد التعامل معها على هذا الاساس انا لا
اعتقد انه في خلفيات العقل السوري ابتداء
وانتهاء عقل الدوله السوريه لا يوجد هناك
خلاف جوهري في هذه الموضوع في هذا الموضوع
تحديدا لان النظام دمشق ابتداء وانتهاء
تعاونت مع تركيا في اتفاقيه اضنه على هذا
الاساس وقبل ذلك تعاملت مع حزب العمال
الكردستاني على هذا الاساس في اكثر من
محطه تاريخيه وهي تعرفهم ربما كمعرفه
تركيا لكن المساله او الخلاف الحقيقي بين
تركيا ودمشق في هذا الموضوع في الوقت
الراهن في رايي الشخصي تتعلق بالاولويات
بين الطرفين وترتيب الاولويات بين الطرفين
بمعنى ان تركي اولويتها القضاء على قسد
والجماعات المرتبطه بها وبينما
اولويات دمشق والقضاء على المجموعات
الارهابيه في ادلب وغيرها وبالتالي اعتقد
ان هناك سيكون مقاربه
لتقريب الطرفين فيما بينهم فيما يتعلق في
هذه القضايا طيب
التركي عفوا العامل الامريكي باختصار لو
سمحت تفضل لا يمكن يعني اغفال العامل
الامريكي الذي هو الذي يقوم بدعم هو الذي
يقوم لتهديد امل الدوله السوريه والتركيه
ويستخذ من هذه المجموعات يعني منصه
تثبيت الدولتين وهذا انا اقوله وانا مقتنع
به
ولتخريب الامن القومي لسوريا وتركيب في كل
الحالات نحن سنبقى في انتظار اجتماع
استانا لنفهم كيف ستكون الامور او ملت
اتجاهات التي ستخذها تتخذها هذه الحلول او
تشكركم هنا في الاستوديو رئيس تحرير تركيا
شكرا جزيلا على الحضور والمشاركه ومندماج
خاصه يوسف الكاتب الصحفي شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات